we're going to pretend that the one
remaining artifact of this two years of
insanity is the mask mandates and
therefore as we either lift them or
promise that they are about to be lifted
you are now you are now back to to
full-fledged humans basically and what
this has done
is cause
essentially you know those of us
who
don't have access to many of the things
that we had access to just two years ago
because we have rejected these
particular
vaccines as either necessary
or effective or safe in preventing
kovid
we do not have access to a lot of things
and i actually think
that
trudeau is an interesting place to focus
here because he of course is
extraordinarily woke he's like you know
the wokest guy to routinely show up in
blackface that anyone can currently
think of um hopefully that anyone will
ever be able to currently think of but
he uses woke as as a as a as a weapon of
course as many people do
and he's simultaneously
doing exactly the opposite of what if
you actually listen to the words of woke
like the honorable fundamentals at the
basis of social justice you know what
are those words that we hear diversity
equity and inclusion right and i was
reminded of this in particular and you
know the the phrase that i came up with
is it's this blind hypocrisy of the
diversity equity inclusion crowd the
woke crowd if you will
when a long-awaited new performing arts
center was announced that it's going to
be opening shortly in the portland area
and i'm not actually i was going to show
the site and go through it but
interestingly they have been changing
the languaging on the site a lot in the
last few days so
because i don't feel like you know
saying okay right now this is what it
says and it's going to say something
different in in
a week or a couple of days
i will say that our local free news
weekly willamette week um
proclaims that this new arts center is
going to be quote a welcoming space for
all art lovers
a welcoming space for all art lovers
doesn't that sound amazing
i
got excited about it i thought you know
finally this is this is this is one of
the few pieces of good news um it looks
like it's in a great place it looks like
it's actually going to have a wide
variety of kinds of live
entertainment
um but a welcoming space for all art
lovers nope that is a lie that isn't a
complete lie because you go to the
website and you click on covet 19
attendance policy and find the same web
uh vaccine apartheid now being practiced
in um you know in some cities across all
restaurants places like seattle and la
and and new york so i understand it it's
not the case in portland there are
there are individual establishments um
that are enforcing um
in enforcing vaccine mandates at the
door and there are many that don't
um
and indeed like i said with regard to
this place they have they have flipped
back and forth between saying vaccine
mandates
absolutely that's it or
vaccine proof of vaccine or
a official formal negative covid test
home tests won't do
you have to it has to match you know
your id this that and the other and of
course these things are expensive
right in fact you heard a story this
week about uh
someone who ended up someone who doesn't
have this money to spend but in order to
give her son the birthday present that
she had already bought for him um
i don't know i don't know those birthday
presents but uh yeah the woman who cuts
my hair uh wanted to take her young son
to a monster truck rally which she
wasn't really looking forward to but he
sure was and then found out having
already purchased the ticket
that there was a vaccine mandate and she
actually suffered a vaccine injury
herself
um so did not want to vaccinate her son
which of course him being a young
healthy boy was the right decision yeah
but in order to rescue her tickets there
was not even a mechanism for an easy
refund um she had to get uh him
a test and of course and it cost a lot
of money i think it was 300 bucks so a
huge amount of money yeah and
um you know just the idea that they're
going to institute these policies
without
considering what this is going to do to
people who can't meet their
demand because of course at some level
the message is well if you can't meet
our demand for
uh proof of vaccination then you don't
really deserve our consideration that is
the underlying message that is the
underlying message and um this place
and other theaters which we have had
tickets to which i have had to cancel
have also been flip-flopping between
it's been vaccine mandate since the
vaccines have been widely available to
people or since the population has been
widely vaccinated
but they've been
flipping between vaccine or or or you're
out and vaccine or a test if it matches
you know if it's pcr if it's within 72
hours yada yada yada and um you know
either way it's it's untenable and it's
hardly about welcoming all art lovers is
it and it's hardly about inclusivity is
it
especially when you take into
consideration that
these are again
experimental treatments that are not
necessary for most people are not safe
for some people and have efficacy that
is dwindling by the moment and even the
cdc admits that now
and
just to go one step farther the fact is
the dwindling efficacy
and
after a very rapid point following
vaccination the fact that these things
are not in any way preventing
contraction or transmission of the
disease means that there is no logic for
requiring people who show up to have
proof of them because it doesn't stop
these things from being spreader events
yeah it can't it the the idea that it is
about protecting other people that part
of the story has completely fallen apart
and
if you want to focus on whether or not
you yourself are worse or better
protected as a result of having taken
this experimental treatment that is a
conversation that perhaps individuals
should be having with one another but at
the public health level the only thing
that the you know the the way that the
messaging has been has been pushed out
and pushed and pushed and pushed has
been about this being the thing that you
need to do for other people it tugs on
the heart strings especially the female
heart strings right it gets to and this
is what we hear also from mothers
telling their their children this is
what you do in order to be a good person
in order to care not just about yourself
in order not to be selfish in order to
be a member of the community who cares
about the people who cannot do this
these things and
that logic has completely fallen apart
and yet the messaging persists and this
is um
actually well okay go on but i i have a
perfect segue there to do what i wanted
to do next all right well i would just
say that the
messaging
continuing on as if
the
uh evidence had not shifted on these
vaccines
is
it is hard to avoid the interpretation
that something is holding on to these
mandates
because of their utility in manipulating
us and in turning us against each other
rather than their epidemiological
reasonableness absolutely and that that
is the thing that we have to worry about
because we are watching
across so many domains uh
rights that are
enshrined in our founding documents for
a reason suddenly under fire like we've
never seen it before
and you know this is happening at a
moment when mysterious forces who swear
that they are scientifically motivated
are being are functioning in a way that
cannot be defended on scientific grounds
and just so happens to have this other
characteristic which is um it amps up
people's fear it turns every person into
a product placement for fear right
that's what the masks have been right
yeah we're all broadcasting this be
afraid message at each other even
outdoors which never made a wit of sense
um and so the point is
i think that
the whole system is like a more
sophisticated version of what happened
after 9 11
with the security theater
at airports and
the
the very the
terror alert system which if you ever
looked into it didn't make any sense on
scrutiny right it was really just a
mechanism for like amping people's
amygdalas right when it was politically
desirable to do so and the fact that it
suddenly evaporated without the cha
change in uh the
the environment
suggested that this that's what this had
been all along
yeah um i mean you and you've talked
about that before on air here i do think
that this what i'm trying to say is
something different that we have talked
about fear we have talked about the use
of fear
and what looks to be explicit formal and
intentional use of fear now
and uh
you know we have posited that
this was in fact part of the plan all
along in fact there is some evidence
from from authorities in various
countries that they intended to use fear
that they understand that fear is a good
way to
uh to change population level human
behavior and individual level human
behavior but what i'm what i'm focusing
on right now with regard to the vaccine
mandates is that this is all but
disappeared from
almost everyone's
thoughts that unless you yourself are
affected by this
even if you oppose vaccine mandates even
if you
um
really think that this has the potential
to bring in authoritarian
horribleness
um you largely are breathing a sigh of
relief now like okay i already don't
have to or i'm about to not have to be
wearing these insane masks anymore
things are finally going to go back to
normal and um in some parts of the
country of course things have been more
or less normal for more or less the
entire last two years and when i say
country i'm you know it's my united
states bias um but in some parts of the
country things have been anything but
and
and frankly it is
this is
a
a more worrying moment in some ways
because
the the de facto privately instantiated
rather than government instantiated
vaccine mandates
are becoming normalized because they're
becoming invisible and we're not even
arguing about it anymore with the
truckers convoy everyone was thinking
about it and they were pointing out just
how awful and divisive and nasty and
anti-democratic and authoritarian they
were and now we're not even talking
about it so i do want to please segue to
the thing that i was trying to get to
many many minutes ago
okay go for it i just want to say that
there it really is a tension between a
unifying force and a divisive force and
that what you are pointing at is that
even with the lifting of these mandates
there is this divisive uh instinct and
uh i will leave it there and we can
segue but
but it is that tension and the truckers
which were portrayed as divisive were of
course unifying that's the point
everything is labeled backwards right
the inclusive of all art lovers thing is
apartheid right
the
truckers who were supposed to be
divisive were actually inclusive and
that's the thing is you have to get used
to a world in which things are labeled
upside down because that's the world
we're now living in and that i mean and
that actually
that applies at sort of the individual
level of you know
we are not the first
to have said this and we've noted it
before here but um
individual
liberals and we still call ourselves
liberals but individual liberals as sort
of a class are much more likely to be
smug
and divisive and interested in mandates
that are exclusionary and certain that
they know you because they know one
thing about which you believe
and individual conservatives are much
more likely to be kind and generous and
open to always
life
and actually be interested in seeing
what kinds of connections can be made
and you know that's the opposite of
what we were told and what we thought we
knew growing up in the 70s and 80s
and there are certainly people out there
who will say yeah that's that's always
how it's been and it was only from
within the liberal bubble that you
couldn't see it and i'm sure that there
is some of that
but i also think the degree of smugness
and arrogance
and hypocrisy is in particularly fine
relief right now with regard to we've
now endured years and the schools are
failing and the media hegemony is is
spreading yes misdis and male
information
in the name of diversity equity and
inclusion
and these these are the people who are
spreading the non-inclusive yes vaccine
apartheid policies
they are the ones doing that
it is it is such a clear case of
hypocrisy it's extraordinary
[Music]
you